non è però book conquilino di merda cioè
dice di una serata dandomi ripropone il
solito finché mi ricorda goffredo marea
ma scusami ma guarda solo i ritmi sta
veramente alla stregua di serendipity
una cosa circa ma tu non capisci con fra
le faceva il doppiatore non te lo
ricordi ogni volta che lo devo
ricordarti capito cambi che cosa devo
fare io la persona da farti vedere tipo
documentario su una vasectomia in lingua
originale anche come ironizzi c'entra
dice tu non sai cosa vuol dire alzarsi
la mattina e non trovare nessuno nel
letto ok tu non hai niente idea di che
cosa si prova a tornare dal lavoro e
vedersi la scossa da solo è lo sai no
non lo sai
eh lo sai cosa vuol dire alzarsi la
mattina e trovare la tavoletta friends
aic non è più caso non è più stata
riscaldata no non lo sai niente tu non
lo sai che cosa vuol dire portarsi su 6
litri d'acqua frizzanti per sei piani
disk o mese ascoltando no non te ma
stavo dicendo ma con frizzante o prima
che la cupezza mi che aspettano sì bravo
bell'amico di merda cioè io sono qua che
vi compito trustee consolarmi che manco
mi ascolti serie a fa a parlare con
patrick e poi vi scrive per primo ho
capito bene
tranquillizzati che tanto che patrick e
finiamo questo qui torno in quanto 81
che per me ancora fresco e bevuto troppo
poco tempo ma come fresca camille cioè
da un anno e mezzo che vi siete lasciati
che è fresca un igloo la nostra storia
tu non hai con risulta l'anima gemella
dove l'hai conosciuto quello che ti
lascio il cuore il cornetto tutto il
male conosciuto uno che anche che ti
molla tramite sms che c'è la stessa
sensibilità di questa mensola che hanno
gli slanci affettivi che in queste palle
di cotone che non so perché teniamo in
casa è uno che ti ha sedotta abbandonata
e poi svanito scomparso man con manco
sirius black vipers alcuna coprendo
matic il cazzo eco freddo coperte
scomparso dalla mia vita io ho fatto un
salto in avanti ed è morto o noioso che
salto in avanti che ancora ti tieni
l'unico regalo che ti ho fatto nella
vita tu ancora ce l'hai tu non è che io
tengo per affetto tu no tu non capisci
io tengo perché in casa ci serve è una
cosa serve se sei un alba capi gnata
arcobaleno utile cosa ne sai cosa si fa
con una turba e film sempre io con
invidiosi
ma ora basta guardarle st pignatale
voglio più vedere sentiti ho deciso
riprendiamoci mano la nostra vita ma la
storia tante ammette luca ciao è che si
va a vivere raccolto ora non posso dire
solito box
ciao si sente me mica posso dirle di non
venire veloci mostrato tranquillo che
quella lì appena dai birre la stende
vantaggio ma che non hai capito
torna pub e quella che sono al mondo
quella annuncia nessuno meno male che ci
sono di amici degli amici saldana che
nel momento del bisogno ci sono
lascia stare una situazione orribile
tentò di rossetti know madame non si può
perché c'è lei non ha capito né a
qualche la notte viene nel mio letto
come gatti ma kimi resisteva goffredo ma
che cazzo sei corse ma il cubano fede
anche a me questa situazione non prevale
ma che ti posso fare e che ci posso fare
[Musica]
facciamo tipo usato la stessa testa
formata sta tornando da una cosa secondo
te aimi se vi piace come il ghiaccio
pensato in bagno ma se ad esempio c
riprendessimo la nostra vita da domani
che con il di sì vedi brava brava brava
brava nina è stato il secondo ormai
fermi ci vediamo più tardi allora io
esco meravigliosa bravissima o io già
vede una luce diversa negli occhi chi
sta da dio il plant ciao ciao
[Musica]